pitt merci madame la ministre la parole
et à monsieur jean pierre decool pour
les républicains
madame la présidente que mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse le seul
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre
fuyant la guerre les persécutions de
nombreuses populations affluent
massivement en europe depuis des
semaines
enfin ça s'est réfugié un devoir moral
nous incombe celui de les accueillir et
bienveillance à ce moment du débat il ne
faut toutefois pas confondre réfugiés et
le grand économique
en effet monsieur le ministre les
migrants économiques n'ont nullement
l'intention de s'installer en france
mais veulent avant tout rejoindre la
grande-bretagne ou les conditions de
travail paraissent plus ouverte
c'est là tout le coeur du problème
actuel
ils ne sont pas demandeurs d'asile en
attendant de pouvoir traverser la manche
ces migrants s'installent sur le
littoral dunkerquois la commune de tt
games dans ma circonscription ou celle
de grande synthe son parti devant
toucher par certains fument stif
les contacts sont saturés les
associations humanitaires débordé et des
forces de police en nombre insuffisant
pour gérer cette situation
les maires du littoral dunkerquois
redoute un cas les bis et ceux d'autres
plus que les réseaux de passeurs se
multiplient et se renforcent de jour en
jour les passeurs esclavagistes des
temps modernes font régner la terreur
dans les camps ces passeurs de recule
devant rien pour tirer profit de toutes
les situations
les trafics auxquels il se livre se font
au grand jour narguant dans leurs
voitures de luxe les forces de police
qui ne peuvent pas toujours intervenir
faute de preuves de moyens sur le
dunkerquois l'étang suscite un sentiment
d'insécurité et la peur cette situation
ne peut perdurer plus longtemps ces
criminels ne doivent pas rester impunis
monsieur le ministre vous l'aurez
compris si l'objectif à court terme est
de réduire l'afflux de clandestins
il faut impérativement démanteler sait
finir ses leurs pattes
quelles mesures concrètes et ferme
entendez-vous prendre afin d'indiquer
les réseaux de passeurs et les mettre
hors d'état de nuire
le député la parole et ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le député de coqs
merci pour cette question qui ont tous
pour des sujets qu'elle évoque juste et
je voudrais répondre précisément chacune
est interrogations vous formulez il est
effectivement absolument impératif de
procéder au démantèlement de ces réseaux
de passeurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans le calaisis le premier
ministre a souhaité que nous renforcions
considérablement les moyens de la police
nationale pour être efficace ce
démantèlement ce sont près de 500
policiers supplémentaires qui ont été
affectés à calais précisément pour
engager cette action de façon
volontariste et je vais vous donner des
chiffres extrêmement précis nous avons
depuis le début de l'année 2015 en
france
procéder au démantèlement de 177
filières de passeurs correspondent 3300
individus dont une grande partie ont été
judiciariser j'ai également souhaité que
nous puissions procéder d éloignement
forcé à partir de calais mais également
de dunkerque pourquoi parce que si tu ne
relève pas du statut de réfugié à
dunkerque comme à calais n'ont pas
vocation à rester sur le sol national et
qu'il est indispensable si nous voulons
envoyer un signal fort pour que la
situation soit maîtrisé que les passeurs
ne puisse plus convaincre des migrants
de venir en france à calais à dunkerque
avec l'illusion qu'ils pourront passer
par ailleurs j'ai demandé aux
britanniques dans le cas de l'accord
franco-britannique de bien vouloir
contribuer au financement à hauteur de
35 millions d'euros ce qui n'est pas
rien de la sécurisation des
infrastructures des transports parce que
c'est aussi un signe envoyé aux passeurs
et pour ce qui concerne qu est plus
particulièrement
j'ai donné trois instructions et je me
rendrait prochainement à dunkerque
première instruction faire en sorte que
les moyens soient confortés des forces
pour leur permettre de faire le même
travail qu'à calais 2 s'attaquer
résolument par des contrôles qui à
l'heure où je vous parle se multiplient
aux filières de l'immigration
irrégulière pour obtenir les mêmes
résultats que partout en france et 3
offrir l'asile à ce qui relève de
l'asile en france pour les dissuader
passer en grande-bretagne merci au
sommet